[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sockin very
excited to be talking about Gnostic
warfare we have Patrick Ryan joining us
on the show thank you so much for coming
on brother
excited yeah we can just restart the
stranger we didn't do an audio check
nope it wasn't on my fault Mic Check we
can to keep its authentic run stream I
don't want it I don't want to do it
twice just do the show I quit completely
okay we have to leave the content will
cover is dead on did you guys shake
hands yeah certainly did okay now do
your intro ready your honor
all right those that don't know Patrick
Ryan's background he has a history
training the chance to attack AI you can
find the links in the Bible occult state
calm as well as his Twitter profile
alright let's jump into things with what
are your thoughts on the direction of
our world we are in the US as a species
we're in the last moment in time where
when AI makes a mistake it's funny
because after this it's bad you're gonna
have a lot of AI neural networks I mean
I'm not even approaching AGI quite yet
artificial general intelligence that's
that's another conversation I'm talking
about the good enough neural networks
that exist today
they can make their correlations they
can figure out the patterns and that's
enough to fulfill an investor or a
business criteria or a profit motive
those that ecosystem of neural networks
is accumulating at a rapid rate and when
we tip over to relying on those
correlations the automation of those
correlations especially when they make
mistakes is no longer funny it's going
to be devastating when they make
mistakes so we are at the very tip of
this period of the ironic shitposting ai
loving worship kind of thing and then oh
my god these things are in control of
policy so when the likes of Elon Musk is
running around a fearful of AI he's
probably not talking about it from a
policy standpoint he's talking about it
from the big mythical monster is gonna
do whatever it wants because it's AGI
and we can't possibly fathom its
intelligence I'm here to give the
opposite message we can beat AI we can
take it down we can dismantle it we can
systematically put it into change we can
disrupt it anything you can imagine
anything that needs to be done to put AI
in its place not just AI Attucks biased
crap that's garbage
I'm talking about attacking its actual
infrastructure getting the results that
need to be done that's my specialty
that's what I focus on so I'm trying to
get ready for that tip where it stops
being funny and it starts being serious
so just in case if we miss program the
first versions of general intelligence
that we need to have our ways of fixing
that error
you're gonna need insurance fall backs
for sure and I always tell people you
don't have to wait around for artificial
general intelligence if you want that
have a kid I mean already their neural
networks in their current form are
probably no more smarter than a
five-year-old for certain domains not
even across general spaces they're no
smarter than it'd be in most cases so a
GI in my humble opinion is still a long
ways off and that's because of the
evolution
the neuron itself which we will get into
but the insurance policies I'm talking
about is when the good enough neural
networks the sort of crap versions of
AGI start dominating the economic space
and the financial space that's the big
one so when the policy making the
economic space is completely driven by
general intelligences yeah that's a
different base entire multiple general
intelligence is not just a single one
that's yes multi-agent come competitions
that thing that's right who's an
ownership who's earning the profits
these types of questions who is it
serving that's right and I know we're
kind of in the crypt of space they're
talking daos distributed autonomous
organizations as a hedge against that
it's not a hedge it's just a channel
it's it's no different than placing a
put it's just a different channel for
investment so I'm I'm specifically
speaking of when these type of pre AGI
soon-to-be AGI sort of methodologies
start dominating the policy-making space
the economic shaping space and the
financial decision-making space and
eventually the insurance space which
they will they're working on you are
going to have policy that is no longer
legible by human beings imagine you know
imagine the right now legal firms are
looking into using AI to find precedents
so ediscovery for example where an AI is
mining through hundreds of years of text
to find a justification for a case
perhaps a case is a murder situation and
they find a precedence involving a very
specific thing from the 1700s and they
use that and build their entire case on
that a human doesn't have the resources
to mine through that much precedence but
AI it's nothing it's just a corpus
review that's it so eventually you're
gonna have a case where you're gonna
have a situation in law just to paint
the picture of how weird this may become
you will have your lawyers the AI you
may have your judges be AI and at some
point the arguments go you made to make
the jury a I so what does democracy mean
then
but peers so it's it's it's gonna go
from silly to serious at some point
they're ideally from the perspective of
the stakeholders and owners of these AI
outfits it is a seamless transition but
it's not going to be yeah from silly to
serious that's what it seems like in
most circles that it's the discussion is
still silly silly silly silly silly and
not yet serious because a lot of us
can't have abstract a trajectory of
civilization and a trajectory of going
from the shitty games of pong that we
had to the photorealistic massive
multiplayer online role-playing games
that currently exist so which is
basically what we're in right now yeah
yeah so when we learn how to abstract
and add the trajectory of civilization
and see an evolution like this and we
really kind of like immerse ourselves in
that more and more often we see the
transition into a very serious general
intelligence as we see it the capacity
to run so many different permutations
creatively as well as for absorption of
evidence and in court all these types of
things that are monkey Minds become a
joke compared to that yeah well they
become a joke I wouldn't throw the baby
out with the bathwater I think that's a
that's a common commonly held hope that
we can transcend our evolutionary chains
and we can somehow become this ideal
platonic human
I often find that the inspiration
towards that goal is more beneficial
than actually reaching the goal I guess
that's another conversation more
importantly that's sort of monkey mind
evolution is a messy thing four billion
years on this planet at least two
billion years for the neuron to get to
where it's at
our our brains stand on the shoulders of
all of those previous neural
evolutionary ideas and in concepts and
winner-takes-all sort of methodology the
evolution of the neuron is a still
difficult thing to examine it's not like
fossils of the brain exist you can't
just go digging through mud and rock to
see brain and grapes somewhere and
hopefully you can make a cast out of it
it's much more difficult it's a lot of
genomics you have to mine through the
history of these sorts of things and
fortunately we are starting to make some
meaningful breakthroughs in this sort of
research there's one outfit in
particular that I'm working with
it's UCSD they have found a way
professor a new tree house a new tree he
had found a way to take Neanderthal DNA
put it into a human stem cell and then
grow that into a Neanderthal brain
organoid so Jurassic Park before tonight
but for Neanderthal brains this was done
exclusively to research the
possibilities of autism diagnosis or
cures or along those lines but the
possibilities are now endless because
now we're we're no longer guessing the
evolution of the brain we can actually
experiment with it and we we are the
23rd hominid by the way we have 22
cousin's before us over the span of a
million years we can pick anywhere along
the lines and we can pick all of them
and literally
map the evolution of the neuron and
start to figure out oh this is why or
perhaps not why but this was the
trajectory of why the neuron did what it
did how did it organize where did
Broca's area come from where did arc
where did our specialization for
socialization come from these sorts of
things can no longer the realm of
academic argument they are going to
become testable theories and workable
experiments and that's going to
profoundly change the development of AGI
I'm not going to hold out hope and God
bless their souls the autists in control
of the mathematics behind the silicon
development the the specialized neural
network hardware the techniques that are
coming out of convolution networks I
mean all the variations believe a deep
belief stuff all the variations and
methodologies that exist bless their our
hearts for trying this game but they're
not going to be able to recreate the
human brain a two billion year engine
they're not going to be able to do it in
17 20 30 years probably not even 400
years it's a monumental task to recreate
what the brain does
and many will disagree with me because
they there is a long-held belief that if
we just map the connectome every single
neuron that exists then perhaps we can
recreate it well that's not true
if I was to take all of your limbs
disconnect you from them and put them
back together to you do you think you
have full motor function there's a lot
of missing data there's a lot of missing
implication that has to be addressed
simply having the parts of the car
doesn't necessarily mean that the car
will drive so the two billion year
process trying to be done in 30 years
ambitious you know so then so then when
we get to the point of being able to
finally piece together a brain that also
is in an environment absorbing inputs
and were able to map exactly what's
happening in the physiology on a
moment-to-moment basis then we're
getting closer and closer we still don't
know you know felt experience
put that into for stuff yeah all that
stuff ok so then now why is the neuron
and consciousness such an important
aspect of the general intelligence
neurons are magic and I don't I try to
embrace as much science scientific
methodology and a lot of my approaches
as I can but there are there are some
times when you just have to back up and
save magic going on here so take the the
very beginning of the neuron let's let's
let's I'll give you a parallel and I'll
explain why the parallel is dumb and
I'll explain how this applies that our
neuron take data science tasks right now
where we are trying to evaluate the
feasibility of a correlation so for
example let's say we're mining Facebook
data we want to find out how people vote
we want to hack an election or whatever
so now what I need to do is I need to
bring on a bunch of cognitive assets
online a bunch of GPUs Asics or CPUs or
cloud servers or whatever I need to
expand these horizontally for all of my
input Facebook has a tremendous amount
of data leaks
I mean data leaks but data oceans at
this point of everything that's
available I now have to go through that
ocean and find the information that I'm
specifically looking for us and now I
need to spin up a huge amount of
cognitive assets to make sense of it I'm
going to make a lot of mistakes in a
process but what I don't realize is the
structural mistake that I'm making I'm I
have to spin up more cognitive resources
to find my answer it's almost like
Zeno's paradox I have to travel half the
distance to travel full the distance but
to travel half I have to travel half but
I have to travel half the more cognitive
resources I spin up online I'm not
necessarily getting clarity I have to
bounce around between different
statistical methodologies or different
types of neural networks or I have to be
mindful of regression or I have to be
aware of the vanishing gradient I have
to be concerned of all of these
different techniques just to get the
answer that I'm looking for and more
often they're not adding more resources
doesn't necessarily get you what you
need it can it can
give you the details of a specific
domain but it's not gonna give you the
grand answer you still have to very
carefully shape what it is you're
looking for within that data ocean you
have to imply a sort of bias in your
question say I need to look for these
conditions and I need to look for these
conditions in these conditions so the
the the nature of your question is
actually forming the description of your
answer the answer isn't waiting in the
pool for you to find the question is
directing you towards the answer and
that can be a bit of a a weird thing
that's a back and forth kind of thing
it's almost like talking to an Oracle to
a degree I'd like if I if I tell the
Oracle my secret passions and everything
else and the Oracle tells me my future
didn't did she tell me the future or did
she just read my behavior it's the same
thing with the data ocean well it turns
out evolution may have experienced this
exact problem and it's all embedded in
the neuron so all of our cells are going
through mitosis at all times our skin is
doing it seven times the second reserve
it's once every seven seconds or
something like that I probably screwed
that number of I'm sorry but all of our
cells by default go through some degree
of mitosis except the neuron does not
now that given everything I've said
about scaling out cognitive resources to
solve challenging problems that sounds
like we got stiffed in the deal wouldn't
it be great if we can just hit a switch
and then it go through mitosis and now
we have more neurons to solve a problem
that sounds like godhood almost and yet
evolution has made that impossible by
default it's forbidden the the the
nucleus of a of a neuron is completely
functional you just can't go through
mitosis they have neuroblasts and they
have the actual neuro tube at the
beginning and the development of the
human brain and so there is a
reproductive strata
reproducing reaper not reproductive but
to create more neurons strategy it does
exist in nature but it's not as free
will as just go through mitosis on a
regular cycle
neurons cannot go through mitosis like
that and that is for our own protection
see while we can go ahead and consume
all of the material world and turn it
into better
and sisters so we can then use it for
our data science needs biology doesn't
have that freedom it evolved a very
different way and so as a result our
data science approach to AI does not
reflect what our neurology has gone down
so as a result from the very jump
we have bifurcated and so we we aren't
going to get to AGI by going down this
road by doubling down on it and throwing
more investment dollars at it you have
to start standing on the shoulders of
evolution itself because it did all the
hard work for us and what does that mean
what is the hard work well the neuron
has to consume energy to live it needs
oxygen 25% of the oxygen you breathe
goes your brain the glucose you consume
if your brain went through mitosis and
you had double the brain in your skull
assuming your skull didn't explode you
would then consume 50% of the oxygen
that you breathe in and now you start
experiencing organ failure so at some
point neurons may have just gone through
mitosis chances are they probably all
died and the only neuron that survived
was that which didn't so now you're
playing a different game you're playing
a data compression game instead of
trying to expand instead of trying to go
through mitosis for every photon that's
hitting your eye which is a bad idea
and yet that's what we data scientist
types want to do we want to expand and
get all the data as much as we can
biology say that's a bad idea I don't
need all the data I just need a
subsection of it and that's enough to
solve my problems these lights for
example they generate a light about
these lights but a light can generate
assuming a thousand watts sorry 60 Watts
will generate 5.2 times ten to the
twenty six photons a second your eyes
receive four hundred million photons a
second that's a huge disconnection of
numbers right so you're if you looked at
a light bulb you see zero point zero
zero zero zero zero zero four percent of
that light bulb and yet it's kind of
pretty the filaments glowing the
ass is going and the ambient lighting is
reflecting all over the place it's not
even 1% of reality you're looking at
this became this became very specialized
over time that's right for very specific
things food mating that type of stuff
that's exactly not to see the atoms that
are in the air right now is right to see
those photons all of them we're not all
over the electromagnetic spectrum were
in a very small band of visible light
yeah and so that's part of this
bifurcation of biological evolution with
the silicon evolution that's right and
that's why in many ways silicon isn't
constrained to 2 billion year
evolutionary periods that's right that's
right because it there's a the silicon
is a derivative of the Industrial
Revolution the chemical revolution which
was made possible by the Industrial
Revolution so we're looking at silicon
as this like primitive cognitive asset
we're treating it as such financially at
least but in terms of the comparatively
speaking against it neuron nor clothes
it's not even remotely similar it's it's
best to treat it as a cognitive asset of
a different caliber the same way I would
look at a scooter or a car I would
deploy both depending upon the context
so trying to merge them together I think
is a bit premature
and it's always sexy to put in a pitch
but when the AI bubble pops and it will
pop people will start to realize that
perhaps the silicon isn't all that is
hyped up to be and maybe even right
before we get there and ask you about
that but just the idea of all of the
sci-fi where the creatures from other
places have just larger heads right okay
so it's interesting to think about the
augmentation of our biology to be able
to fit something the that has the same
maybe neuronal density as our own brain
that is 10 times the size of it that
could potentially take in other aspects
of electrum
a spectrum or just balance out like 8
billion world views at the same time
there you know things like that because
if our struct if we were you know
20-foot creatures with massive brains
that type of thing that then maybe we
could somehow more rival or general
intelligence in terms of computational
capacity sure that's a that's a common
trope in sci-fi we're experiencing right
now we're experiencing that problem
right now right now with the Neanderthal
brains so they can be grown to about
maybe that big right now after that they
require a lot of maintenance the
nutrition bath can't have any
contaminants in it the serious problems
in that regard which can be overcome the
the biggest problem of all is vascular
ization getting blood veins to move
through the brain
obviously the blood-brain barrier being
what it is the neurons aren't taking the
oxygen directly there was a filtration
system but it turns out that the veins
are taking heat out of the brain the
veins do act as thermal pipes and if you
don't have that thermal piping the brain
will start to collapse so to get the
veins you need blood flow for blood flow
you need a barrier for a barrier you
need up you know heart to pump it for
the heart you need a liver for the
filtration and now you need lungs and
all of a sudden you need a whole body
just for the brain the body is the
minimal Viable Product for a brain and
that's a we didn't know that until you
started growing the brains and so there
are problems with just simply growing a
brain naively for example there's one
technique Siamese twin incandescently if
it was feasible to CRISPR a certain part
of certain part of an embryo in vitro or
otherwise what you do is you Siamese
twin the brain it's you actually just
that part of the body and you have a
higher density but unfortunately upon
doing so now your skull gets a little
bit bigger your neck muscles have to
support that your glucose consumption
gets out of whack
you have organ failure because your
oxygen is consuming so this industrial
bias where we can just scale
because we've been in an industrial
civilization for the past 200 years
that's sort of scale up excuse me that
scale approach biology doesn't play that
game biology is the intrinsic
exponential technology it's the very
first and so it plays by a very
different set of rules
what is the AI bubble yeah so Google put
eight billion dollars into robotic firms
between 2012 and 2016 and their final
conclusion was that reality is hard
those are actual words reality is hard
after 8 billion dollars that was their
summary there right reality is hard it
took 2 billion years to understand
reality enough to keep DNA going but
robots we there are still problems when
you're dealing with with video frame
analysis where you can't track the
object between frames that proves to be
an ongoing issue our eyes don't have
problems with this when I when I look at
that pen I don't see 80% of a pen and
20% of a spaceship I see a pen it's
either there or it's not but because of
our statistical fundamental statistical
approach we'll neural networks it's all
statistics the whole way down which
means it's derivative of set theory so
our brain isn't operating in set theory
I know there's I know uh what's-his-face
at Facebook is arguing that the brain
does back propagation this is this is
absurdity this is complete bonkers
thinking every civilization since the
Industrial Age has thought that their
peak technology is an analog for their
brain the Victorians thought the brain
was a giant steam engine or a tiny steam
engine so we're playing that dumb game
still and this bubble will pop not
because the technology is bad it's not
that it's bad it's good enough it's good
enough to deal with financial problems
when you're dealing with high-frequency
traders or you're trying to do some
degree of geopolitical analysis I've
seen some of the AI stuff being pitched
to the military it's not good I'm not
impressed I've seen a lot of the
feedback from the Air Force regarding
that
they're basically saying yeah
another AI product give us something
useful we're over here trying to sell it
as the sexiest thing ever invented and
these generals already bore the tears
with it because it's not doing what it's
supposed to do it's being oversold and
overhyped
the data poles are too big the the
experience of these tech firms in the
space of geopolitics is too narrow they
don't have a firm understanding of all
of the complexity in all of the edge
cases and you can't do the agile
approach you can't do it er ative things
and geopolitics like that you have the
policies they said the treaties are
there etc etc so you can't take this
iterative approach and say oh well a
thousand people died because of my
policy let's change our code it's it's
politicians lose their job over [ __ ]
like that so so are there's a lot of
tension between what's needed versus how
we're going about doing it sucks
so let's hit on like on a trajectory of
civilization we are now at this
inflection point like you said at the
very beginning and so it seems as though
like narcissism is also coming in to
some sort of a play esoteric mystical
knowledge what is actually happening on
this planet that caused us to somehow is
it just chance that from the Big Bang
here we are 13.8 billion years later
after four and a half billion of years
of evolution on the plane it would to
specialize in Iran like they're talking
about now we're breaking apart with
silicon as well is this just all chance
is there something beyond the 3d reality
that is at play here that is that is
mystical or spiritual that is at play
here sure so I'll give two domains of
answers first I'll focus on the material
then I go esoteric I out of everything
I've seen on the material I'm kind of up
still if he owned Big Bang I know the
problem is trying to address I look at
the numbers I look at them mmm I'm kind
of iffy about it the fine-tuning problem
does not sit well with Big Bang
fine-tuning is
why is the electron at certain mass it's
a very specific number if that mass was
up or down any variation whatsoever the
entire universe would not exist so to
get that level of specialization usually
implies trial and error which means more
than one big bag means repeated big
bang's this is where someone named Lee
Smolin comes in he gets laughed at I'll
get laughed at everybody laugh at Lee ha
ha ha I get it but he puts a good
proposition out there see it's different
it's almost impossible to prove but it's
a fun proposition for it's for thought
experiment value mr. Smolin puts out the
idea of the fecund universe where you
apply evolution to the generation of
universes so there's a birth and if the
conditions are right it dies whether
dice fast or die slow who knows it
propagates and that in turn generates
another universe so forth and so on
indefinitely this is how you can end up
with the fine-tuning number of the
weight of the electrons so materially
speaking there is an importance at
looking at evolutionary mechanisms in
cosmology there is a value to there
whether it's true or not whether it's
provable or not leads us to our next
point which is the esoteric and
specifically epistemology mm-hmm we're
starting to hit points where in the
higher echelons of in the higher
echelons of academic review we are
starting to deal with high energy
experiments or tremendous galactic
distances cosmic distances where we have
no way of actually proving any of our
postulates at all light moves only so
fast there's a specific thing called the
bekenstein bound for example where a
particle can move one direction and a
particle can move the literal opposite
of it and if they're at the right
velocity then even if this particle
emits light it will never reach this
particle which means this particle is
invisible to this one and vice versa so
it's not a question of exploring the
universe the relativistic velocity
between the two is so is at the right
number where they are permanently
invisible in
even influence one another so is the
universe the observable universe there
are parts of the universe that we will
never ever see no matter how much our
science progresses so now we have a
problem we know there's a universe
beyond there it's almost like someone's
like UFOs
we're pretty confident there's other
extraterrestrial life out there but why
aren't we poking it why isn't it here
why aren't we touching it why aren't we
hugging it there's there's questions
like that that kind of linger the Fermi
paradox sort of approach same thing
happens with the bekenstein boundary we
know there's a universe behind that that
had that veil that can never transmit
information to us we know it's there we
can't confirm it you can't do a damn
thing with it so now we're talking where
science fails where the scientific
methodology in particular fails where
you can't experiment with it so what
does this mean well now we're talking
about the failure of the what I'm going
to call the the progressive reliance of
mathematics and this is going to be
controversial I'm sorry but the idea
that if we just math harder then we'll
get more secrets of nature if we just if
we do the numbers and we run the
equations then perhaps a better
understanding of the universe will come
to us and when you look at the sunken
cost fallacy of that that's worked for
us we've sunk in tremendous amounts of
resources into building these
mathematical humans it's been going well
this computers here the millions of
people could potentially watch this
obviously we're surrounded we're
drowning in the mathematics of our
previous success so for me to say that
as a bit heretical however when you're
dealing with these high energy
experiments and these cosmic distances
the problem arises itself in a very
naked way so what does this mean it
means that perhaps representing the
University of mathematics is good enough
but there might be another model I'm
starting to suggest that perhaps the
basic nature of the universe is actually
cryptographic okay
so when you're dealing with these
problems where you cannot know
epistemologically where belief and and
truth are are really mess it's a mess
when they over lash overlap this is very
similar to a cryptographic problem if
you were a code breaker
you would be looking at ways to there's
there's two there's two code
methodologies in particular there's a
AES and then there's one-time pads AES
was made by NSA it is a symmetrical
encryption where usually if you do a
weighted analysis on a crypto stream you
will find that certain letters used more
often than other letters and that can
help you narrow down what words were
actually using and then decipher the
whole thing and post there your options
broken but with a symmetrical approach
every letter is used equal amounts of
times so all the biasing is gone so you
can't actually figure out what the
message was about so is this like the
heart and science harder and math harder
is for like if the universe was open
source code but because it's
cryptographic code then we need to also
mysticism harder as well s science
harder that's exactly it because when
you're trying to break a cipher you can
math as hard as you want there's no
amount of math you can throw at a
cryptographic balance symmetrical
encryption you can't break it with math
there's no amount of math you can use to
break a one-time pad that's out the
window no but you could enslave every
human being ever to be born turn them
into mathematicians at gunpoint
turn every particle in the universe and
the transistors to do the math to break
a one-time pad you still couldn't do it
so now we have a phallus and we have a
limitation a horrid limitation of math
and yet this limitation of math comes
from math all the cryptographic stuff is
a derivative of mathematics it's
interesting that mathematics can
actually form a construct that it itself
cannot resolve that's a very interesting
idea this is starting to style sound a
lot more like mysticism
so if we treat the universe as a
cryptographic in its constructs as
cryptographic in nature we can
apply math you know if the further
everything out but you will then realize
oh where these edges exist we can now
start looking at it and approaching it
cryptographically we have to start
finding biases we have to start finding
implementation mistakes or weird things
like the fine-tuning problem the
electron mass that's a weird bias that's
probably indicative of some
cryptographic pattern but start hacking
that so if you if you keep a sort of a
code breakers mentality when looking at
the limitations of where math and nature
don't really mesh well together
I think cryptographic can fill in the
hole quite well and that leads
immediately to the mysticism so that
that's how I transition from a material
to the mysticism is the cryptographic
constructs give you that bridge because
now you can start applying epistemology
to these deeper concerns in a material
way not just the esoteric booboo crap
but I mean actual material games ok and
now let's hit on the actual training of
attacking the general intelligence right
so there's been a period of time where
we've started to control and modify
human behavior that's become more and
more common now it's probably most
prevalent now with all the algorithms
embedded in the technology that that SAP
our attention is to do that most of us
still think that we're in control but
we're absolutely not in control
so that's but this has been a long
period of time of modifying controlling
human behavior yeah so what specifically
were you doing in your journey of
training the chance to attack AI what
does it look like to leverage
evolutionary biology to hack a I will
get into the metadata graphic the
butterfly war - yeah yeah yeah so I came
to Hollywood to learn propaganda that's
why I went there the the inspiration for
that was
he's not a Scientologist but I just saw
it from afar you see all these
investments and all these stars and
they're all in the Scientology I'm like
now wait a second that's not even all
that good sci-fi if people are willing
to pay that much for Z great opera how
much are they willing to pay for the
real thing that was my reason that my
that was my justification so I came to
LA to learn all that stuff and see what
were they doing that was working and
what were other people doing that was
working how are they bending these
photons in these sound waves to get
people to change their behavior that's
all that's all this stuff is I mean all
this digital tech and media stuff we're
just bending photons and delaying when
they get released that's basically it
but it turns out our evolutionary
preference is for the visual cortex for
almost a lot of what we do
we've specialized for socialization so
heavily and so as a result being able to
read or decode the emotional intention
that is within those photons is very
very vital so if you are well before I
go there I found that people who try to
explore this topic they have a heavy
linguistic bias they tend to think of
the human experience exclusively through
words this is interesting to me because
I've never seen it through words I tend
to be quite good at words but but but
versus feeling versus social interaction
versus relationships social interactions
yeah exactly so where you have this
linguistic bias when examining human
history it's more important to keep in
mind that when human history started
there wasn't much in terms of
linguistics so that bias is
intrinsically wrong
you can't utilize it you have maybe two
300 words tops about 2,000 years ago
they weren't even full blown words or
grunts or noises whatever symbols
symbols symbols are essential we'll
definitely get to that in a second
symbols were essential but but those
symbols were still powered by something
even more prototypical where if it's you
and me it's 200 it's 50,000 years ago
we have a loose lexicon but we're
working together because we're part of
the same tribe our mothers know each
other nature being what it is we're
bound we rely on each other and we're
relaying useful social information
towards one another about what we intend
to do what's going on where we've been
who this person is who that is and we're
doing this exclusively with our bodies
we're doing this with our positions and
our postures you can walk in a room and
read a person right now you can walk in
a prayer room right now read a person
just by the photons that are bouncing
off their bodies alone just look at that
frozen belly gaze probably mad or happy
or drunk whatever you can read that on
the photons alone not a word said those
symbols even in play just on the photons
could you tell I was insane you're
you're the extension of your hands and
the freezing of your limbs yes so the
the photons themselves packets of light
they have a polarization they have an
amplitude they have a frequency but
we're also encoding emotional
information on them interesting light
hits me bounces off me the shape and the
delay the frequency the colors and
everything bounce back to you you're now
digesting them through your rods and
cones through v2 of through V one two
three all the way up and now you're
extrapolating and pulling out the
emotional intentions that are somehow
encoded on this photon stream and this
is what your brain is doing whether you
like it or not we're all doing this
sorry guys it's evolution so we're all
doing this and this is the foundation of
communication before words before
anything else before psychology before
sociology before even religion this is
how we were communicating intrinsically
it's just just reading these photons
dreams once I realized that I started to
reconstruct history okay okay how does
this lead the symbols how does this lead
to the preservation of symbols why do
symbols have the power they have what's
so good about a color in a and a shape
and a
a symmetry why is that so alluring well
turns out no kidding that's what we're
looking for inmates that's really what
it boils down to so so going back to the
example where if you were to expand your
neurons to take in as much photon data
as possible you would fall over dead
it's more important instead to
extrapolate what you need from that
photon stream what you need from that
stream is prey mates danger that's the
basics optimization function that's
right
and those are the basics you can go from
there that's the foundation and all the
noise is gone and all the signals it's
not processed as yeah it's it's it's not
as priority yeah but I wonder if it's
gone I'm still working on that I was
starting to embrace an idea called
cognitive entropy you'll see this being
represented by the likes of Carl first
day he's doing a lot of work on the
Bayesian brain and he's built an
entropic model that relies on dopamine
as the heat analog but the thing about
entropy and its equilibrium to the
layman but there's a there's always one
concept of entropy that gets lost and
that's the waste heat you can't you
can't talk entropy if you if you're not
going to describe the waste heat so this
is order and equilibrium the equilibrium
between disorder and order and how they
are influencing and how they how they
strive for that equilibrium by default
mm-hmm but there is a waste heat
mechanism the work goes in the system
sorry the energy goes in the system the
work comes out and the secondary output
is waste if you want to model the brain
as an entropic process you have to
account for the waste and that's where
things get dicey swear you're mentioning
three right okay so how let's lead this
then into actually leveraging many
biology to hack AI yeah yeah so in this
case looking at this reconstruction of
history seeing cognition and trying to
explain as evolution Wyatt gloms on the
certain symbols Wyatt gloms on the
behaviors on what it's actually
selecting for this entire time I was
then able to look at the internet and
see it in a very different perspective
so for most people it's the internet you
Google you get stuff you win everyone's
happy or you interact with the people
you start a flame war you troll you ban
someone everyone's not happy it's one of
the two in this case I was looking at it
sort of like a sociologist paradise
where people were willingly giving
information about themselves without
ever knowing they were doing it it's not
a question of filling out a survey I've
been able to find people just by
analyzing when they posed you got to
sleep sometime and so if I take all your
posts on Twitter I can look at your time
delay and I can figure out when you're
posting to figure out when you sleep if
I figure out when you sleep then I know
what your time zone is of a note your
time zone is I know where you live
bang just on that alone I figured out
where you live you didn't know you're
putting out that information but I put
it together and that's an example so you
can take a lot of secondary examples
like that if I'm getting linguistic
analysis a sentiment analysis I'm
looking at your usage of caps looking at
your usage of punctuation even if you're
more formal and you're typing versus
when you're less formal in your typing
that indicates an emotional state mm-hmm
so you can collect all this sort of
information and I was doing that
originally with my brain I found out you
could do it with a neural networks later
on but I was originally doing that well
mind when I was analyzing the chance I
was looking at 4chan a particular way
back when and 4chan is a special special
place it's unlike anything that exists
in the sociological experiment if you
look at tumblr or Facebook or Instagram
they tend to specialize for certain
types of human expression the Chan's are
very different because they don't play
the social media game when the internet
first came out it was mostly everybody
was lying about everyone you had no idea
who
was I could change my identity proposed
it was all linguistics they did it was
too expensive for a camera
what do you had to take a picture you
had to get a develop you had to scan it
you had to put it to several floppy
disks you had to upload it to the BBS
and hopefully other people would get as
way too much work so these these easy
low-hanging fruit means of forcing
identification weren't available too
early Internet users all they had were
words so you get different types of
social interaction here you get more
honest types of social interaction I
don't mean honest in the terms of
critical exploration I mean honest in
the terms of humans being animals yeah
because there's no way to verify if
someone is who they say they are so
there's no way to put social punishment
upon them and that's really that simple
so that goes back to it's not a curated
feed of my best self
you could still curate even in an
anonymous space but the nature of the
anonymous space means no social
ramifications for social interaction yes
no wait a time you we look at the way
that we portray ourselves on the current
social platforms that are not the chance
and that's it's always the best self
it's the best self and Instagram in
particular and then of the chances I'll
say what I want when I want
yeah how I feel yeah and you will hear
it for me and you will hear and that's
why it seems more primordial instinctual
animalistic and less so I'm not curating
my best self all the time precisely
it is human expression in its most
honest form that you can possibly
collect it which is why it was an ideal
candidate to review and reuse okay keep
going them on that thread so when you
have that you can actually start
exploring emotions you can start
exploring
you can explore humans independent of
their social bindings and that's
valuable scientifically at least because
that will give you that individual at
that time in which culture and family
raising and moral structure is
significantly minimized yeah not
entirely gone but it's significantly
minimized
now even then there's still a medical
Chur about the chance which is
interesting the idea that we're gonna
we're gonna get rid of all the
contemporary cultures and all of the
Industrial Age cultures and the TV
cultures are not toss it out the window
with the exception of anime because
that's Chan culture they formed a meta
culture about themselves it's almost as
if they removed all the cultures just to
build their own that was interesting
they formed groups of people where
honest communication was valued and
hated simultaneously and what would end
up happening you would see these even in
that space where it's just what looks
like complete noise to the average
person and it looks like just a
waterfall of hate but if you're really
big into it you will see people
communicating with each other in the
most genuine manner possible because
they recognize this as truthful you
can't get that on social media where
there's identity because there's always
a secondary game going on mm-hmm
there's always the game of signaling or
posturing or whatever the peacocking of
things Chan's you don't get that if I'm
connecting with a person on the Chan's
it's because we both recognize the rules
of the game and oh [ __ ] you said
something that actually moved me and I'm
I'm now compelled to actually do
something with this information the only
thing you can do on the social media
platform is share share you that's
that's your that's your it's that's your
interaction that's oh you have your like
people throw likes like it's cheap
currency people share like it's
expensive currency so you can either
spend your crab cash or you can spend
your gold and they it's almost like
Gresham's all's in effect people throw
the crap social interactions around all
day but the shares on one day really
they only share that because it's
reflective of their reputation on the
social networks meanwhile in a chance if
something actually moves you you're
compelled mind body and spirit to
continuously act on that sort of that
experience that you went through it's a
spiritual movement it's a transition
entirely it's outside of sharing the
least thing you do you're transforming
yourself to now align yourself with that
honest truth that was there it doesn't
happen often I'm not I'm not telling you
you're gonna find you know boot on the
way to the [ __ ] post but it does happen
and I started chronicling those events
and looking at where they were binding
and how they're interacting and I saw a
common thread I saw this general
disillusionment with the way things are
I mean it's pretty this obvious they
were they were different than the way
they were looking at it they wanted to
do something about it
it wasn't throw my hands up it's
nihilism let me do drugs until I die
sort of thing it was this is [ __ ] up
and I want to do something about it and
I'm anonymous and I can do something
about it and it won't get back to me so
the social punishment was entirely gone
they were free to act and they were free
to do things in which the traditional
means of keeping them and check were
completely gone hmm this was all I
needed this was all I needed because
this was this is a an army waiting to be
organized and so I started looking at
the primary people who are trying to
stop them I didn't get an answer at
first
there's too many you start talking that
game you start talking conspiracy theory
and that's not helping anybody because
you have to yep you can want a
meaningful target you got to hit
something that really really resonates
so for a long time I didn't have a
target but I kept I kept interacting
then gamergate happened and oh my god oh
you could probably have me back just the
talk gamergate cuz there was so much for
those who don't know gamergate was this
weird cultural explosion where so much I
don't even know how to make it concise
it was
I think 20,000 members of 4chan got
banned because they went after some
terrible game but the game was made by a
female and so it turned into this big
battle of the sexist sort of thing and
it just exploded out of control it's a
mess absolute mess there was there was
no rhyme or reason or sense to any of it
but no one had ever seen chanters
getting banned like that that doesn't
happen
that's a board we're a terrible place
anything happens to her you don't get
banned you have to go out of your way to
get banned from 4chan but these guys got
banned in mass and that tells us those
who are familiar with the chance that
this was an inside job this was the mods
being compromised they were
intentionally targeting these people and
just smacking them and getting rid of
them that was bad and this took all
these all these other people who were
wrong the chance but kind of fell out
but it brought them all back and now
there was a standing army who were ready
to really attack this problem at hand
because it went after the one point in
their lives that was actually constant
that where you had these emotional
connections and you had this serial
spiritual transformations going down the
temple was now desecrated effectively
and it brought them back to movement and
they turned into a massive massive force
that bordered on the line of political
we saw this with the advent of when when
Miley innopolis comes down to defend
gamergate when even the likes of Mike
Suresh come down defend gamergate early
on these were people who had transformed
a lot of the talking points that were
being thrown by the supporters which I
didn't get into and I should have when
this sorry I got a back step I got a
backtrack of it when the when the people
got bent there were these 10 news
outlets who came out with this
coordinated hit that said gamers were
racist and gamers were that was terrible
things in history and kill all gamers
and [ __ ] them and this that and the
other
this is coordinated media hit against
them which of course attracted the
opposite to come and support the gamers
research this on your own where you can
it's it's it's tough to research because
a lot of the a lot of the material has
been manufactured to make gamers look
more demonic than they actually are
they're not Saints they're [ __ ] but
they're not demonic this was the sandbox
in which all of these things were
possible all the things I'm talking
about because now you have this high
explosion this high emotional content
going on in these contexts where you can
you can try an idea and it gets rapidly
consumed and rapidly evaded and it falls
this is this evolution chamber of
emotional Simba logical steering trying
to build an army that's what I was
trying to do build an army that can
actually have an impact in the real
world and it came to a head with the
advent of the butterfly war that's a lot
and we have the graphic now that we can
bring up on for the butterfly war and so
now we have this this these the the
humans and Shann that have been treating
this is a sacred space to be able to
galvanize them yeah okay and then use
that for attacking artificial
intelligence right and so I had realized
very early on that the only way to go
after the chance was to use AI do it you
can't use social punishment you can't
shame them it's all anonymous so now you
have to use statistical analysis of
their metadata and their behavior to try
and suppress them so they were ground
zero for the censorship stuff that's
starting to take place now and I saw
that very early on I said no we're gonna
do we're gonna have to go hard of a eye
on this one because if you went after
the political players they just swap
them out mmm like oh this figure heads
down bring in a new one that wasn't
gonna stop him that aslam added up the
AI weakness was so ripe
so misunderstood that it was a perfect
target and so what I did was I started
channeling what I had known about the
evolution of Neurology to figure out the
mismatches between what a eye is doing
and what humans are doing and I found
that AI was making a lot of mistakes
that usually gets smoothed over because
of scale so for example if you're asked
to lay concrete on a street as long as
you get ninety percent of it who cares
of ten percent of it's cracked it kind
of finished the job so you're good
enough
that's how AI sort of approaches it when
you take an AI approach to censorship
we've banned a good chunk of the bad
behavior but the outliers also got hit
by the stuff and that's dismissible
because we own a large amount of the
ability to tell people why what we did
was good the Silicon Valley has the
ability to own the narrative as well as
own the censorship tech simultaneously
so it's a very interesting duality but
there are certain people under American
law that you absolutely positively
cannot target they are called protected
classes okay so yeah the red lining was
this concept in the 70s and 80s where
banks would not loan would not give
loans to African Americans because they
didn't have the collateral arrangements
or they had a history of poor payment or
the perception that they had a history
of poor payment so this is called they
will draw red lines around the maps of
districts or they wouldn't issue loans
this was considered unconstitutional
across the board by their 70s and 80s so
this was a huge violation to banks had
to restructure their entire practices
around this
and it wasn't even as if that particular
population was driving a huge part of of
loan demand most of the loan demand was
coming from business and middle-class
White's at that time it was as if they
were trying to protect their portfolio
from potential risk or the illusion of
risk of whatever the case may be and
that was sort of their justification but
that all changed under law they changed
that entirely but that opened up
something called disparate impact this
root impact is a fascinating piece of
legalism where the courts basically
throw their hands up and they say well
we can't define what racism is but if
you can convince us that something as
racist will believe you that's
interesting mm-hmm it's quite
interesting it's almost sort of like
democratically determined what's racist
and then will come down and say you this
violates civil rights law or whatever
the case may be like what's kind of
happening with the censorship right now
that's what I'm trying to make happen so
the thing is that you can't necessarily
make AI target something it doesn't want
to target when you have let's say the
googles and the and the Twitter's of the
world let's say they have a staff of
really zealous true believers who really
want to double down and eliminate all
these people who deep platform all of
these people who who don't deserve a
voice and they have beautiful
justification for it I mean it's real
sexy slick stuff they're throwing out
their very believable stuff especially
for people who aren't in the trenches of
it I mean you'd look at the board bill
yeah screw those guys do you platform
them very sexy stuff you won't be able
to convince them to go after these high
threat targets and high threaten in
terms of targeting protected classes
trying to make AI methodologies say
we're going to
people who are african-american we're
gonna target people who are Muslim we're
gonna target people who are female does
that any other that's a no-go from the
jump no one's that dumb that you can
convince someone to do that but there is
a way to make them do that
so this is where butterfly war comes in
when Charles Darwin first started
evolution ice theory of evolution who he
described a great number of animals and
their evolutionary behavior in patterns
but the butterfly was a perplexing
creature he couldn't quite explain why
the wing of all the way it did it didn't
make sense the last thing you wanted to
do was have this attractive wing because
clearly you get picked out of a forest
with yellow wings as a predator that's
giving them free food effectively so why
would these things evolve with bright
colors that would attract predators and
guarantee their deaths it didn't make
sense until this guy named Franz Muller
came along naturalist in the 1800's he
said ah well what if the butterflies
taste bad okay so what this means is if
I eat a butterfly and it tastes bad the
predator will avoid it mm-hmm
it'll also avoid anything that looks
like it mm-hmm so what this means is the
butterflies will start to adopt looking
like bad tasting food mm-hmm interesting
idea it gets worse it turns out this bad
tasting strategy will jump species other
species will embrace the colors of bad
tasting the colors and patterns of bad
tasting food and and they gain of equal
protection from the predator now when
you take this entire interplay and
overlay it across civil-rights the exact
same thing happens where so if we're
seeing the way that people are being
censored and then we act as bad tasting
food to not get censored yes that's
right so in this case the bad tasting
food is going after the protected
classes because if you do that the
federal government will come down on you
have you handed and just to give you an
example the Little Rock Nine I think
that's the number when civil rights was
first rolled out in the school system in
the south and Arkansas Eisenhower
deployed the freakin military to
escort those children to school so the
executive has already established a
precedent to say we will deploy the
military to protect civil rights that's
all there that's from the jump so that's
that is a be careful against attacking
these groups of people it will taste bad
so all you have to do is make your
device's generate the metadata of that
group that tastes bad and now you can't
tell them apart there's nothing you
could do so now your policy your
censorship policy will turn around say
well these white nationalists are
pretending to be pretending to be blacks
too to do all these things and we have
to now stop them and now what you're
doing is are coming up with this
ridiculous policy where you're now
saying well these behaviors are what
real African Americans do these
behaviors are not what they do so now
you're coming up with it's phrenological
concept where you're trying to classify
these protected classes into what
acceptable behavior they knew versus
what they're not allowed to do it
becomes messy really quick and you're
gonna start accumulating a tremendous
amount of collateral damage as a result
of your censorship policies and you can
automate the production of these memes
and then all of a sudden you have
billions of these bot farm memes that
are spreading and then it gets really
messy when they're it's like oh we need
to hit this we need to turn that one off
when you turn this one off to a sensor
that sensor this sensor that and it's
like that those aren't even real
accounts over there oh my god and then
it yeah it's messy and so that creates a
free-speech environment that it creates
it eventually results in a date on where
the Silicon Valley will have accumulated
a significant amount of collateral
damage which will result in ball suits
you will see this with cannon Owens by
the way her what she's doing will result
in one of these which Kansas owns yeah
that will happen and it's already
happening with change the more and more
that's right that's starting to play out
she's gonna leave the spear on that
there'd be a lot more follow-up do you
there will be a redlining event in
Silicon Valley it will happen we're
doing what we can to make sure it
happens but the the Silicon Valley gets
called out call it out on ya because
they're already doing it they're just
not getting caught doing it they're
already creating cyber phrenological
profiles of minorities to market to them
ones last time you saw an ad for like I
don't know
Popeyes chicken or something like that
probably didn't see that I don't see it
no one's seen it certain groups see that
when's the last time an african-american
making $20,000 a year saw an ad for golf
clubs right it's nothing so they're
already building these profiles of what
is and what is an acceptable
african-american behavior what is and is
an acceptable female behavior they're
already violating civil rights they're
just not getting called out on it
they're not getting caught doing it so
if I if I if I'm a woman and I'm a
certain age group in certain City
location certain income level I'm gonna
be targeted in a specific way because I
have built a psychrometric profile and
I'm being sold [ __ ] that I don't even
need or want that's right these types of
things and so to be called out on that
and to say that hey how do we have a
global conversation about your role as
the as the store of all of the knowledge
of civilization for us to query how do
we either figure out how to decentralize
you make it so that all of civilization
can partake in a way that's fair and
just and that's right
that's great peace and dignity involved
in it and not that's controlled by a
handful of people yeah it's heavily
centralized and that's one of their
downsides the more centralized they
remain the more prone to butterfly war
they become they have to split up in
order to survive and endure they have to
allow different perspectives to exist so
so decentralization prevents butterfly
world yes that's correct
because then everyone has a perspective
at that point you're not collecting you
will still be collecting metadata
on individuals and their psycho
demographics I suppose it's the word for
it but the control over who can speak
and who cannot speak and who can
influence and who cannot influence that
gets destroyed yeah yep which is already
getting to become quite intense yes
right now
all right wrapping wrapping thoughts do
we covered I think we covered things
quite well so then with the
decentralization we feel like we can
tackle the the AI arms race the multi AI
arms race yeah and get some water for
this one yeah so butterfly war is an
example of what I'm calling Gnostic
warfare when you're trying to trick an
AI and in the case of butterfly war what
you're doing is you're sending medet let
me explain them the mechanism in full
the what you're doing is you're sending
metadata of your device up to Google
until they show you the ad of whatever
protected class you want to see so I
will send my accelerometer data my swipe
data not my text not my sentiment not my
stuff like that but all the other
auxilary stuff that's more trusted
because it's assumed that people can't
hack that sort of thing you send that up
until you get the ads you want and then
you know that you've convinced Google or
Twitter that you they think you're an
actual protected class now okay and they
have to do that because that's how
advertising works they have to show you
the ads so they're screwed they've
opened up their adaptation loop they're
Oda loop so you can totally exploit that
this is an example of hacking an AI no
matter what it's it's a full hack of an
AI it's not just hacking the the
training cycling the the Train period or
or hacking the fine tuning in this case
we're hacking the secondary policies and
we're going after the culture that those
training and Retraining is allowed it's
a complete and total multi-step hack
that even you can fix one part
fix the other part and it's been in the
end of process of fixing one part you're
actually exposing that you're violating
civil rights along the way so this is an
example of Gnostic warfare where you're
it is a total engagement of every part
of the AI infrastructure not just the
tech side of it yeah there's plenty of
there's plenty of situations where that
which maybe we can also do in the second
second or so yeah and the second
conversation let's let's save let's save
a lot of what we're about to hit on the
second conversation there's this is I
think this was would you agree it's
pretty decent on the first time oh yeah
absolutely all right it should it should
raise enough questions just to recap
Elon Musk is running around talking
about Eli talking about a AI that's
gonna be terrible to beat and I'm here
giving manuals on how to be de I so
hopefully people will find that useful
yeah interesting
super counterculture I love it super
open-minded to what this is are we in a
simulation
there's one test I've seen that can
confirm that it's using x-ray gamma rays
what you do is the way gamma rays move
through space they are considered
maximum density energy and the way they
move through space can betray the
metadata of why they move through space
and that's being used as a metric to
answer that question so I'm holding out
to see the result of that one
interesting I don't think anyone's
answered that with actually we've talked
about being able to poke at the
simulation with the scientific probe
it's a gamma rays may be a best way to
do so yeah interesting yeah okay and
then what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world beauty
esthetics beauty
the most beautiful thing in the universe
is a mind unburdened by its own context
unburdened by its own context yeah free
as free as you can get it get it this
has been awesome fabric I've had such a
blast oh yeah so good man thank you so
much for coming on thanks
yes pleasure yeah there's been so much
good stuff to unpack really excited for
round 2 we'll make that happen thanks
everyone for tuning in we'd greatly
appreciate we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode go and start talking more about
Gnostic warfare go and start talking
more about how to attack or hack a AI
about ways to spread memes through
things like metadata butterfly wars
these types of things the have the
evolution of neurons evolution of us
talk to our friends families co-workers
people online of social media about
these things let's get talking more in
building more about it you shout out to
round of August for producing and
directing thank you very much Ron check
out the links in the bio to cult stay
calm as well as Patrick's Twitter check
those out and also support the artists
entrepreneurs the communities around the
world that you believe and support them
help them grow support simulation our
links are build our patreon a paypal our
crypto currency links also if you want
to design merch get paid and spread the
Opera looking questions are UV link is
below as well and go and build the
future everyone manifests your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thanks for tuning in and we will see you
soon